wir leben in einer Zeit weltpolitischer Krisen.
wusstest du,
Sarah Wagenknecht plant eine Offensive gegen die AfD.
oder Anders gefragt,
wie ehrlich meint es Wagenknecht mit ihrer neuen
eigenen Partei?
es gibt immer mehr Konflikte,
immer mehr kriege mit gefährlichem eskalationspotenzial.
und ausgerechnet in dieser Zeit hat die Bundesrepublik
die wohl schlechteste Regierung ihrer Geschichte.
eine Regierung,
die planlos, kurzsichtig und in teilen schlicht inkompetent
Auftritt und handelt.
der Name dieser neukründung lautet
Bündnis Sarah Wagenknecht.
doch was steckt hinter ihren Motiven?
viele wissen nicht mehr, was sie wählen sollen.
oder wählen Aus Wut und Verzweiflung rechts?
aha, da haben wirs.
und schon jetzt sind es laut einer
inselumfrage ganze 12 Prozent,
die das bündniswagen Knecht wählen würden.
eine Zusammenarbeit mit der AfD schließt sie übrigens Aus.
demokratisch, findet ihr nicht? auch eure Meinung,
wie immer in die Kommentare.